here's Adam kinzinger he's also a noted
liar and he's calling Tucker a liar so
liar liar pants on fire here we go
but he doesn't care because he wants
people's money he is an unserious man
who is doing serious damage with the
cooperation of Kevin McCarthy who wants
to have Tucker Carlson on a speed dial
because he likes to impress people in
the room with who's on his speed dial
this is dangerous and uh you know
Michael finone will tell you about how
all dangerous that was because it was it
was a really bad day that is being
whitewashed but the kids of the people
that believe that somehow that wasn't an
Insurrection they're gonna they're gonna
know better and the parents will never
admit they ever believed it in the first
place it's just words they just put
words together to scare people and
Tapper sits there with this fake news
Man glasses and pretends that it's all
real
again where are the plans was anyone
taken over the nuclear codes were
military members running into the Senate
under the auspices of trumpton and mega
wishes and gonna take it's all silly
drivel uh here is uh Jake Tapper and
Jake Jake the thing with Jake is he was
the one semi-sane guy there but I get it
if you're if you're in a mental let's
say you're a semi-sane guy and they
throw you unjustly into a mental
institution which is what MSNBC and CNN
in this case are eventually you're going
to go crazy too because it's it's hard
to be the one same guy at the mental
institution you know I actually had a
cousin who wants something happened she
got unjustly thrown in into a mental
institution for a weekend and she came
out crazier than she went in it's a
freaking long-ass story I'll tell you
guys some other time but that's what in
essence happened to Jake Tapper uh here
he is gaslighting his own audience into
pretending that fox believes that
January 6 didn't happen at all you know
I know it probably is pretty upsetting
personally to have been there and in
your case uh officer Fanon to have been
physically harmed severely and see this
entire presentation pretending that this
didn't happen uh and I want you to know
we see you we know it happened and
I don't know what to say about this
except I'm sorry
we see you like he's an avatar remember
the Avatar we see I see you I see you
something
look nobody on Fox I've watched enough
of the clips nobody's saying it didn't
happen the question is what actually
happened how did it happen and to what
degree was it actual criminal behavior
and intentional versus just saying it
was an Insurrection and it was the worst
thing ever and people should be thrown
in jail and have trials delayed and they
should be an isolated uh you know
containment and all of that stuff
ha
[Music]